we'll have a conversation with zach
zach good afternoon um how can we help
all right how's it going guys
outstanding how are you good man
uh doing pretty good uh just had a quick
question wanted to get your input on a
situation that i'm going through
um so a few weeks ago
we were driving down the highway my wife
sees a little boy standing by the road
and uh he decides to throw a big huge
rock at our car
so pretty fun well uh
you know we pull in the little boy takes
off running in the woods
end up long story short we talked to the
boy's mom
she she says that she's going to handle
the situation you know whatever it costs
to get the car repaired
big thing in it scratch the paint you
know
whole nine yards so yesterday
i went to get the car looked at to see
how much it would cost
so i get the estimate and i contact her
and she's now saying she's not gonna
help at all you know she's not even
offering to do anything
so being a christian you know i want to
do the right thing
and i want to you know i want to make
sure that
i'm not just getting run over as well
you know so
i'm wondering if i should take it to
like a small claims court to try to get
the money it's
it's like a little less than 900
so should i just let it go or should i
do what i can to get the money
to get the car fixed do you do you have
insurance uh
zach yeah i do but i mean
you know it caused my rates to go up to
apply my insurance so
yeah yeah um
what do you want to do man
i mean you know i go back to the word of
god and
you know it's like i've been forgiven of
so much
so i want to forgive it and just say you
know what just let it go but at the same
time i mean it is going to have to be
taken care of and we don't have the
blender to do it so
i don't know i'm just kind of torn
got you you don't have an emergency fund
zap
no i don't okay all right all right
here's the thing
it's going to cost you uh some money to
go to small claims court
um and here's the thing too if she
doesn't have it
she's not going to pay for it even even
if so here's here's the deal
uh i'm friends with the lady on facebook
it's a small
town here she's on facebook you know
asking about how to get the new
playstation 5 and
talking about you know how good her
husband's job is and stuff
yeah but she's telling me that she has
no money to say
well zach so once once you get into her
try to get into her head yeah once you
try to imagine what's in her checking
account you have
left the idea of justice and you've
you've wandered over into retribution
okay okay and so that
if this isn't a a church service type of
show but if you want to get into the
biblical part that's
that's the that's the concern there um
right
there's a difference between i need you
to pay for something that you damaged
and then i'm going to pile on and i need
a million dollars for pain and suffering
right so there's a difference between
justice there's a difference between the
right thing to do
and then there's a difference between
retribution
so i don't i don't see any moral or
legal or spiritual obligation
uh i mean spiritual challenge to you
going with the rules of the society that
we all live in
to get your car taken care of i also
want to want to really suggest you lean
into what anthony was saying
at the end of the day you're going to
have a lot of heartache a lot of drama
a lot of a lot more expense than you
think so
yeah going after seven eight nine
hundred dollars
and something that a kid did yeah and so
at the end of the day you're gonna have
to sleep at night with whichever side
you choose
i will tell you that if you start trying
to figure out what you think she's worth
and what you think she
how she should be spending her money and
that is a fool's errand you're gonna end
up you're gonna end up like the federal
government
where you're going to be sitting across
an aisle from somebody throwing crayons
at each other
um trying to solve problems um what
you're saying it's just
it just kind of feels like a you know
being spit in the face it's like i don't
have any money but yet
you know i can't help you out but she
already agreed to help you know what i'm
saying charlie agreed to take care of it
sure just kind of well here's the things
like it's laughing the face
this is here's the thing zach and i'm
gonna be honest you are being done bro
i'm gonna be real with you yep her son
did it and she said she'll fix it
and now she's coming now she's coming
back i think dr dean and i are both
agreeing
what's happening to you is wrong
okay we're not we're not trying to take
up for her what we're trying to do is
help you move
forward in a peaceful way and so if i
was you
this is what i would be doing it's not
what dr d be doing maybe but it's what
i'd be doing
i will unfollow her from facebook i
would reach out to her one more time say
hey ma'am i
really need this taken care of your son
did this you all are responsible for
this this is putting me into a bind
can we handle this peacefully um
before moving forward and just give her
that opportunity and then from there
if she says yes figure it out if she
says
no then okay thank you so much and then
if you want to take it to small claims
court
you you have every legal right to do so
but i'm not taking her the same to small
claims court because i don't have time
for the frustration
the drama the issues over 900 we're not
talking about 9 000
we're talking about 900 and dr d
this is why dave hogan
myself rachel this is why we talk about
having an emergency fund
right because in situations like this
life happens
and this wouldn't be an extreme
emergency this would just be like a dang
man i wasn't supposed to do this but hey
i got to take care of it that's right
you know and and i what you just said
anthony is so wise
here's what he can control his side of
the equation yes
unfollower from facebook yes right if
you think somebody has shown their
character
on the internet which i'm always going
to debate that because that's
fantasyland um then you can spend your
energy and your
soul and your blood pressure yeah trying
to go to war in fantasyland or you can
just hit the unfollow button
you know what some of my friends would
do and america do not do this we're just
on the show having a conversation
my friends my friends will guilt
if she posted about the playstation 4
she he they would literally go in there
like hey
you're gonna buy a playstation can you
fix my car first right right right so
don't do that don't stoop to their level
right you stay high
and just focus on your piece moving
forward focus on the things that you can
control
and do not stress on the things you
cannot control right